every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed you know I bet that
you'd be fine without me hello everybody
welcome to the minimalist podcast where
we discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less before we get
started just a quick note we are sitting
in Airbnb bed room right now Sean is
holding a microphone between me and Ryan
and as we record this because we wanted
to get this out to you in time we've
been on the road for about a month now
sharing our documentary with a bunch of
folks so we're going to share some stuff
with you today by the way my name is
Joshua fields Milburn and I'm Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists and today is finally the day
it's May 24th 2016 and that means that
our first feature-length film minimalism
a documentary about the important things
hits
hundreds of theaters across the United
States starting today and it will also
be in Canadian theaters starting on June
8th you can find your closest theater at
minimalism film comm slash watch you can
also pre-order the film online at the
minimalists comm slash order Sean will
put those links in the show notes for us
as well oh and good news everyone who
attends a sold-out theatrical screening
as well as everyone who pre-orders the
documentary on Vimeo which you'll find
via those links everyone who does that
will receive 6 hours of bonus interviews
and additional content ok let's move on
to today's episode today we're going to
share with you a few scenes from
minimalism the first Ryan we should
probably talk about why we decided to
make this phone yeah man
it's really hard for me to believe that
it's been 6 years since we started this
website the minimalists comm yeah since
then we have written hundreds of essays
on minimalism we published three books
about
intentional living we've toured all over
the place just bringing our simple
living message to millions of people
across the globe we even started this
thing called a podcast which should be
obvious to y'all of course because
that's what you're listening to right
now yeah you see we are constantly
finding new ways to spread the word
about minimalism that's why three years
ago we decided to make a documentary and
you know we didn't want it to just be
the Josh and Ryan show now I know me and
Ryan we are awesome let me just ask us
but seriously we wanted to make
minimalism a bit more accessible we
wanted to show you all that minimalism
isn't a a radical lifestyle it's a
practical life style so we and our
talented director Matt Dee Avella and
the amazing team over at spire media we
went out and interviewed dozens of
minimalists from all walks of life
we interviewed minimalist families
minimalist entrepreneurs minimalist
architects and artists and writers
environmentalists and even minimalists
from the sustainable fashion industry
we interviewed economists
neuroscientists neuropsychologists
sociologists tiny house designers and
journalists and even a former Wall
Street broker and what we discovered is
that while all these people will lead
considerably different lives they all
share one thing in common they're all
striving to live a meaningful life with
less so in this first clip from
minimalism we hear a bunch of experts
discuss some of the problems of
modern-day consumerism yeah what you're
about to hear is sort of an amalgamation
from a neuroscientist named I'm sorry a
neuropsychologist named Rick Hanson an
entrepreneur named Jesse Jacobs
a sustainable fashion consultant named
the Shannon whitehead also a
neuroscientist Sam Harris an economist
named Juliet sure an author and
technologist Patrick Rome and there's a
filmmaker in there his name is yarrow
Cramer and all of these interviews all
these snippets helped us start to
outline the
yes that we have created in our consumer
driven society
at a time when people in the West are
experiencing the best standard of living
in history why is it that at the same
time there is such a longing for more I
think of that as a kind of biologically
based delusional craving that Auto
craving is a good strategy to keep
animals alive including early human
animals in really harsh conditions but
these days today it creates a disconnect
you're like a puppet whose strings are
being pulled by mother nature and
evolution reaching back tens of millions
of years we still feel Restless we still
are always scratching and clawing for
more
it's why lottery winners are miserable
it's why homeowners have three car
garages
the first car creates an exponential
awesome rush of happiness and joy and
utility the second car comes about
because we tire of the first car and as
humans were wired to become dissatisfied
it's an addiction really and we are
encouraged to maintain the addiction
through technology and information
American culture has for the most part
these blinders on there's definitely
this illusion of what our lives should
look like
whether it's advertising or your
Instagram our Facebook feed it's this
illusion that our lives should be
perfect it's natural to use other
people's lives and even imagined lives
you know that the confections we see in
advertisements as a yardstick the open
Vanity Fair or Esquire and you see very
sexy and glamorous lives and then the
projects for most people seems to become
you know how can I get that or as as
close to that as I'm gonna get
there can be an immense amount of
dissatisfaction and trying to live that
way
and many of us see no alternative but to
live that way
advertising has polluted an infiltrated
culture it's in our movies it's in our
television shows it's in our books it's
in our doctors offices it's in the taxi
cabs it's in the bar sitting next to you
the person who you think you're just
having an idle chat with could have been
placed there by an alcohol company
it's been slow evolution this is not
something that just happened yesterday
this is something that has been sold to
us over say the past hundred years
slowly but surely by those that want to
make they want us to believe that you
really need these
every year that passes there's more
stimuli there's more pressure with more
options as more media as more noise
noise noise and by streamlining
simplifying and just letting people know
that they have the option
it's that wake-up call that is really
valuable and in a very critical time
right now next here's a clip from Ryan
and me discussing our our troubled
childhoods
now while Ryan and I aren't we're
certainly not the the main focus of this
film our story is sort of the the
through line that carries the the
narrative of the documentary forward and
really creates a narrative for that film
and so it was really important for us to
highlight some of our backstory
including some of the the childhood
problems that led us to these these
overindulgent 20s that we had you know
through over indulgent lives that we had
throughout our 20s you know at the time
before we were minimalists from the day
I was born until the second grade when
my parents got divorced I had like the
perfect quintessential mom and then when
my mom left my dad she just really went
off the deep end
by junior high we had a lot of people
over at the house and later I found out
they were in there smoking crack they
would cook crack by the eighth grade the
SWAT team was kicking in our door
busting my mother for selling drugs
it was a drug that that overtook my
mother Josh had a very similar childhood
to what I did
my very first memories of my father
extinguishing a cigarette on my mother's
chest surely after she left my father
she she started drinking it was my
biggest fear that I was gonna get taken
away from her when she was sober she was
a phenomenal mother I think she kind of
felt trapped my mom always complained
about money she didn't have any money
I remember being poor growing up and I
remember thinking when I graduate high
school I want to start on a path that is
gonna take me somewhere other than a
struggle
okay guys finally here's a clip
featuring Leo Bob alte a husband and
father of six and there are some
additional clips featuring minimalist
parents David Freelander and Jacqueline
Schmidt as well as a snippet from an
interview with Joshua and Kim Becker all
of whom discuss living as minimalist
families so I've heard someone say
there's another word for minimalism it's
called being a bachelor
so that's yeah I mean I could see how
people would think oh that's really easy
if you're not married and you have no
kids how do I set an example of myself
being married and having six kids which
is totally unknown I'm Alice and very
ironic how do I live a minimalist
lifestyle with those kinds of
constraints Declan I haven't been too
prescriptive about like no you have five
toys you know no dude you can only have
one truck you can't have three trucks
you know it's like now when I was a
little kid I didn't have one GI Joe I
had like 100 GI Joes we've welcomed
things into our life but definitely with
the intention of thinking about what
we're doing as opposed to just consuming
when you live with other people and
you're a family you can't just make
unilateral decisions okay we're now
getting rid of everything and throwing
the TV out the door there will be a riot
that's a little bit frustrating because
you can't just get your way but it's
also a really interesting experiment and
how you can move together as a group and
learn about this together as a group
at the very beginning when we decided to
live with less we knew early on that
minimum lives is just gonna look like
the way we wanted it to look
I remember going through getting rid of
things and finally saying okay Salem
what's go through your toys and let's
get rid of some of the things you don't
need anymore
and he had no problem whatsoever my
daughter is seven and she is very
different
she loves every doll that she can get
she collects rocks twigs and anything
else you can find she she collects and
she holds on to you know as parents we
get to set some boundaries for her but
ultimately we we let her choose what she
wants I think he certainly has been at a
different level of minimalism than I am
he wanted to get rid of more than I
wanted to get rid of and so there comes
to compromise his side of the closet
looks much smaller than my side of the
closet and that's okay with us
the only thing one of the lessons that
that we've learned through this whole
journey is just that our kids are really
watching us and we can tell them that we
want them to be certain people but man
they're picking up a lot more just from
how we how we live our lives
this is undercurrent of consumerism
removing some of that good stuff
provided a safe environment where
they're able to become what they most
want to be rather than what the the
world will try to convince them to be
okay that's almost it for this week we
hope you get a chance to see the film in
theaters starting today or order it
online at the minimalists comm slash
order and instead of closing this
episode out with our normal beautiful
theme song by Peter Doran what we'd like
to do is leave you with a song from the
film's soundtrack but first let me let
me just talk to you about that
tract so when we started making this
documentary about three years ago well
then you can go back a little bit
farther
I had a journalist asked me recently
during an interview trying to warm up to
me I guess asking you if you were stuck
on a desert island what's one album you
would you would what's the one album you
want to have with you and my answer the
canon ii pretty quickly was an album by
a band called parlor Hawk from Utah and
it's the self-titled second a second
album of their such is called parlor
Hawk and it's just one of my favorite
albums parlor Hawk is definitely my
favorite bands they have only two albums
and so when we started making this film
I knew that the music for the film would
be really important and so I reached out
to the lead singer of of parlor Hawk and
spend about six months sort of begging
him his name's Andrew Cap'n ER and
eventually he agreed to do the
soundtrack the entire soundtrack for the
film and he partnered up with a
grammy-nominated producer a guy named
Nate Piper and they made this just the
most beautiful soundscape that was the
the perfect illustration of the perfect
backdrop for this film and and so what
we'd like to do is leave you with with
one of the songs from from that
soundtrack but if you leave here if you
leave this podcast with one message as
always we hope it's this love people and
use things because the opposite never
works and now here's a song called
end of the line which is written and
performed by a band called we vve and
that is Andrew Cap'n ER and Nate Piper
they formed that band just for this
soundtrack and so if you try to google
them you not gonna find anything but
that soundtrack will be available really
soon on iTunes and I think they're gonna
put it on Spotify as well so you'll be
able to look out for that more details
coming on that soon but I hope you enjoy
this song
you